and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber testimony
continued on Monday as singing sensation
Ed Sheeran tries to keep a civil lawsuit
at Bay in New York you see the fight is
over whether he just took inspiration
from a classic song or outright copied
parts of it let's get you caught up to
speed on what's happened so far let's go
back to 2014. Ed Sheeran released the
hit song Thinking Out Loud but then a
few years later a woman named Catherine
Townsend filed a lawsuit claiming
copyright infringement she is the
daughter of Ed Townsend who actually
helped Marvin Gaye write the iconic love
song Let's Get It On Townsend claims the
songs are too similar last week Sharon
got on the stand to defend himself
saying there are only a certain number
of musical notes and chords out there so
some songs are just bound to sound
similar he even brought his guitar to
play for the jury now it's not the
lyrics that the jury will consider in
this copyright fight it's the actual
Melody the harmony the rhythm of the
songs based on the sheet music which
brings us to what is called musicology
the plaintiffs are hired a musicologist
to testify about the similarities of the
songs you see it can be hard to parse
out the similar chord progressions when
you hear the two songs played but once
you break them down into their
individual Parts it is easier to
understand musicologists can be called
as expert witnesses to talk about the
music industry as a whole as well as
issues like licensing co-writing using a
song for parody Judith Fennell is a
forensic musicologist who testified on
behalf of the plaintiffs in the Blurred
Lines lawsuit several years ago you
might remember this one Marvin Gaye's
estate had sued Robin Thicke and
Pharrell Williams saying that Blurred
Lines copied Gay's hit Gotta Give It Up
thick Williams they lost they were
ordered to pay five million dollars plus
half of any future royalties for that
song big judgment there well we sat down
with Judah Fennell to get her take on
what's going on with the civil case
filed by Katherine Townsend and how it's
similar to that Landmark Blurred Lines
case Plus in the end what will really be
the outcome and what's it going to be
based on
in the end though if there's a lawsuit
the lay listener is is the eventual
judge and jury if you will
meaning that the untrained listener your
average juror who has probably little or
no musical background is making a
decision based on really their that
particular persons or that group of
persons people their perception of what
they're hearing and as I say in this
case
the present case as well as the earlier
case involving Marvin Gaye's music the
recording by Marvin Gaye
um is not being permitted I believe it's
based on the copyright that protects
only what you call the composition so
it's only what is called a lead sheet
that was submitted for copyright you
know in a legal sense was submitted for
copyright protection so the only thing
that the analysts can look at is what's
on the lead sheet not what's on the
recording which should include a lot of
other features
and that's the challenge of the present
case with Mr Sharon as well as the one
involving um Pharrell Williams and Robin
thicken which I testified
musicology so interesting all right time
to bring in one of my co-hosts former
trial Attorney Terry Austin Terry this
is your wheelhouse civil law but not
only that you were inside the courtroom
to hear the testimony and evidence talk
to us about it well Jesse both sides are
fighting really hard to win this case
but I was truly impressed by the
humanity between these parties Catherine
Townsend was back in court today for the
first time since she collapsed on
Wednesday reportedly due to a medical
condition this morning before court
began Sharon actually approached the
planer's table and embraced her she
thanked him and hugged him back that was
really refreshing but once Sharon got
back on that stand for the end of his
Direct in the beginning of his cross the
gloves came off Sharon criticized
plaintiff's musicologist and said the
first 24 seconds of thinking out loud
was nothing like let's get it on he
literally said he thought what the
expert was doing was criminal frankly I
was surprised that it wasn't an
objection to that comment now Sharon
also played again today in court and he
combined several songs with the same
chord progressions including Crazy Love
by Van Morrison which was recorded even
before let's get it on so essentially
Sharon is saying two things first the
chords are not identical and secondly
the chords have been used by multiple
parties countless times now no matter
who wins or loses this case we're
definitely going to witness a huge
battle between the two and the outcome
is going to be significant to the music
industry Terry I'm jealous you got like
a free concert not all of us can get
that in a courtroom very good great
reporting as always
long Prime daily everybody so we go now
to Idaho where doomsday cult Mom Lori
valo dabel is being tried for murder and
on Monday there was a huge Revelation a
direct connection between Lori Val one
of the children She's accused of killing
seven-year-old J.J valo she's also
accused of killing her daughter Tyler
Ryan but more to that in a second long
crime correspondent Gigi McKelvey is in
Boise Idaho with the latest details on
the testimony as we enter another week
of trial
I'm Gigi McKelvey outside the Ada County
Courthouse bombshell revealed this
morning in the Lori valo trial her hair
was found on duct tape that accompanied
the body of J.J valo so that was the
first big bombshell next up we had a FBI
agent who is walking us through the
timeline in the cell phone pings of
Lori's brother Alex Cox who is believed
to be the killer of the children as far
as him going to gun ranges and shooting
ranges on the day before and the day of
when Tammy dabell was shot at also
purchases were revealed that he made the
day of including a ski mask a black pair
of pants and a pair of gloves that can
be fingerless if you flip back now the
relevance of that is that on the 911
said the person who attempted to shoot
at her with what she thought was a
paintball gun had on nothing other than
a black mask that he bought at the
Sportsman's Warehouse that very day
stay with a long crime Network to bring
you the latest I'm Gigi McKelvey from
Ada County courthouse and that is not
all on Friday Tammy dabell's sister was
back on the stand Tammy was Chad
dabell's wife when he met Lori valo Chad
said Tammy had been sick and he woke up
one morning to find her dead and autopsy
wasn't performed but Tammy's body was
later exhumed and it was determined that
she died of asphyxiation just a couple
of weeks after Tammy's death Chad and
Laurie got married in Hawaii
did you ask Chad about whether or not
Laurie had children yes I did I asked I
asked him in a phone call I said so
please tell me about this woman that
you've married to replace my sister with
and he told me that she had had a hard
life
and that the reason why they hadn't told
me
her name was because she was trying to
you know stay away from the stigma of
what had happened to her and I said well
so
please help me understand so now that
you've married her are there children
because I had seen the other information
and I said are you going to be raising
kids together you know Mark will be
coming home from his mission and he told
me no
that there's no children and that they
were going to be empty nesters
time to talk about it Terry joins me
again as well as defense attorney Brian
buckmeyer so Terry I'm going to start
with you real quick let's go back to
Lori's hair being found on the duct tape
for a second that feels like pretty
damning evidence in a case where there
hasn't been a ton of forensics tying or
into the case well that's right and
frankly I was very surprised to hear
that all of us I think as far as
reporters are concerned are thinking
that of course she has been charged with
conspiracy to commit murder and murder
as far as the children are concerned but
I don't think anyone ever thought that
she was actually taking part in that
murder actually helping to kill JJ and
Tyler we've always thought at least
based on the reports we've seen that
Alex was the one who was there perhaps
Chad day Bell was there also was on his
property he at least maybe was helping
with the burial we're all speculating
just based on the evidence we've heard
so far now that this hair is in evidence
we are really now able to tie Lori to
the actual murder and I think the jury
hearing something like that but having
hair in the duct tape that was on JJ is
definitely going to hurt her defense and
Brian gwillum spoke a lot about Chad and
Lori getting together pretty quickly
after Tammy's death why is that coming
into trial what's the prosecution trying
to do with it Terry I think it goes
together with all of their storyline the
why for these murders the motivation
behind killing these children and
getting the money it was for these two
to come together so I think whether you
want to call it res geste which is the
fancy way of of saying completing the
narrative or completing the story or
just saying that this is the connective
tissue that's helping the jury
understand why this was all going on
according to the prosecution I think it
works well and it's right for the judge
to bring it in now some of the defense
try to poke holes but it seems pretty
resistant to any hole poking especially
when you combine the DNA and the hair
you thought the timeline the statements
were bad now we're getting a little bit
of forensics I mean the prosecution is
building a case and they are building a
case against Lori valade